hey hi samuel leeds here and on this
video i wanted to give you
five tips for if you're starting out in
property or you want to be
a property investor entrepreneur then
these five tips
really should help you in getting you
started
so firstly is to just set a realistic
goal i speak to a lot of people and they
want to be a property investor they want
to be a property entrepreneur
and they've either got absolute pipe
dreams pie in the sky
i want to be a property
multi-millionaire i want to be the next
billionaire and
they've got no plan they just have some
big wish
and that's what i call it i call it a
wish whereas you want a plan so say
realistic goals don't set your goals too
low because most people's problem is not
that they set their goal too high and
don't hit them it's that they say it too
low
and do hit it you want it to be
realistic
but at the same time not pinellas gotta
have a clear plan so an example would be
let's say you're 26 years old
you're just starting out you've got 5
000 pounds in the bank a realistic goal
would be to say i want to be financially
free in 12 months
i want to have three properties and i
want to have a real
depth understanding about property that
would be realistic
unrealistic would be i want to be a
billionaire too low
would be i just want an understanding
after 12 months i mean come on you want
to get some results so set a really
realistic goal have a plan that'll be my
first
tip number two once you've done that
don't be afraid to tell the world
what you're doing most people they try
and be secret entrepreneurs you know
they're closet investors
and what they want to do is they want to
quietly build up this property portfolio
then tell their parents tell the world
ta-da
i've done it you know did it all in
secret it doesn't work like that
and here's why because if you're doing
it in secret
you won't get any support you're worried
about getting hate you're worried about
having people trying to hold you back
just get over it that is going to happen
i'm a multi-millionaire i still have
haters and people trying to hold me back
today
so forget that if you don't speak it out
no one's going to support you
because although i have the odd hater i
also have
thousands and thousands of people
supporting me and backing me so if you
say
guys this is what i'm doing i want to be
a property investor i want to get three
houses in the next 12 months
what will happen is you'll get a couple
people hating on you trying to hold you
back but you'll also get people
supporting you and when you
speak it out you speak it into existence
because also when you speak it out
you're then accountable
you're accountable to the whole world if
you say guys
i'm going to lose a stoning weight over
the next six months and put it on
facebook you've then got to do it
because you said it and you don't want
to look stupid
so whereas if you just quietly want to
get on with it
you've got no one no one to be
accountable to so really important don't
miss that point tell the world
join the facebook group over on a
facebook group it's free to join
property investors with samuel leeds and
just go on there and just say hey
this is my name this is what i want to
do this is my goal this is my realistic
goal
tell the world and you'll be really
amazed at what happens because when
you're thinking and talking not much
happens but when you start moving people
just get out your way
number three find friends find friends
that are doing the same thing
what you need is you need success
buddies i did this when i started out
and i was just 17.
i joined networks i went on training
programs not only did i find a mentor
and not only did i go through the
training which is
vitally important but i also found
friends because if your friends are all
broke
then the chances are that you'll be
broke if your friends are all miserable
you'll be miserable because you are the
makeup of the people that you spend the
most time with
so find just two or three really good
success buddies people that you can hang
with people that believe in you people
that are
for you that are cheering you on you
really need that and that way if you've
got a few people in your family that are
like are you idiot you know you'll never
do it you're not good enough
then you've got friends that are
cheering you on and it compensates
so you really need that again go on the
facebook group you can find some friends
there
come down to my property investors crash
course you'll make a thousand friends
there
but just however you can just find
people that are supporting you
and never ever ever be a dream stealer
of somebody else
never be that person if you ignore
everything i say in this video and you
don't go on to be successful and you
don't want to be financially free
never rob somebody else's dream but i
would say never rob someone else's dream
and have your own dream and find friends
that also have their dreams encourage
each other
it's a massive massive help number four
is as well as learning you have to
unlearn
everything that you think you know about
property you've got to unlearn and the
reason is is because
what we are taught in schools and what
we see on the media and on tv and from
the government
is mostly just a complete lie just to
keep you in your same position to keep
you working a nine-to-five job
to keep you going to university getting
into debt the system is designed for you
to be poor
and for the banks to be rich that's how
it's worked for the rich to get richer
for the working and middle class to stay
broke that's how it's designed so
you've got to unlearn what you know
about not only finances and the economy
and work ethic but also property
the stuff that you've been watching on
homes under the hammer
and all these property shows a lot of it
is not quite
true at the moment when you're looking
at houses you're probably thinking in
terms of
your feelings and thinking very
romantically you know i'd have to move
into a house
with my partner and we could do it up
together and then we could sell it and
live in it
oh isn't it romantic and all that stuff
is just you trying to kill
two birds with one stone trying to be mr
or mrs romantic
you've got to unlearn that and you've
got to look at this as a business and
you've got to look at this as i
facts formulas over feelings and
emotions
also unlearn a lot of the stuff that
you've learned about security
and school and education and and
property and
money being in the bank is safe i'd
really recommend reading this book by
lowrent high this is
uh my property best-selling book it will
help you unlearn some of the stuff
when i started in property one of the
reasons i became so successful i think
is because i was young and i was naive
and as crazy as that sounds sometimes
young people learn best because they're
just like a blank slate
ready to learn whereas if you speak to
people that have already maybe got one
property investment
and they're in their 50s and 60s
sometimes they're hard to teach because
they've got all these misconceptions and
they've got all these fears and they're
so
wrapped up in the house has to be close
to my house
because that way i can manage it even
though you shouldn't be managing it
anyway
and they've just got all this stuff
actually you don't need to know that
much about property to be successful in
property
you what you need to know is you need to
know about how to make money unlearn
be open be coachable be ready look at
this as a business
rather than feelings and romantic
wouldn't this be wonderful so
that's really important i hope i explain
that well i hope you kind of got the
idea of that
that's number four lastly number five
you need to become
best friends with right move open rent
gumtree zupla whatever the sites are in
your country you need to become best
friends with the online listings where
they list properties
constantly be looking at what's coming
up for sale in your area what's selling
how much it's selling for
what properties are renting out for
what's empty at the moment
what's going on and just be like a
little property nerd
i do this i'll be in bed and my wife
will be like dude are you literally
still
looking on right move because i'm just
i'm obsessed
with seeing what's selling what's valued
at what
so make right move be your best friend
because if you don't know what's on the
market
if you don't know what's selling for
what then actually
you're you're not that relevant in the
place in this space so
just get addicted to all the property
sites set up all the filters so that
every time a property comes available in
your
in your patch you get a little email
alert um
subscribe to this channel turn the
notifications on so you're getting an
alert
just become like a property nerd
where you're just obsessed with seeing
what's selling what's
going view houses and you've got to be a
little bit obsessed you've got to have a
fire that burns in your belly
for success but you've also got to be a
little bit obsessed
with the business as well with property
so really just get your hands dirty
don't be afraid to travel three hours
across the country to go and view a
house
just be prepared be prepared to work so
they're the five things the five top
tips that i would say if you're starting
out
in property i hope that's been really
useful please do share this video
comment your thoughts below if there's
any other stuff that you're doing that's
working really well comment below i'd
love to know what's working i might be
able to put it in my next video
if you've got questions about any of
that as well pop the questions in the
comments i try and
respond to uh as many as i possibly can
especially in the first
hour mentoring monday 7 p.m a video goes
live
for the first hour from seven till eight
i am on it i'm just there like i'm a
little nerd on youtube like answering to
all your comments so
get yourself on at 7 p.m every monday
i'll answer all i can
and god bless you peace out i'll see you
next time thanks so much for watching
thank you so much for watching this
video it's mentoring on a monday
every single week at 7pm on a monday
between 8pm
i'm gonna be live answering all your
comments and questions don't forget to
subscribe
right over here so you'll never miss one
of these videos i'll see you next week
at 7 p.m
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need this in your life
you can get it from amazon for 10.99 or
a gift from me
absolutely free down below in the
description link i'll see you next week
monday at 7pm